is Jesse Williams at BuzzFeed in New
York City apparently I am here to play
with puppies and answer fan questions
simultaneously told you I was down bring
em in bring em and these things can't be
together that's cute
dammit you're cute hey buddies what do
you guys think I should answer first
let's go to the bottom
first question what Grey's Anatomy
episode did you enjoy filming the most
and which episode was the hardest as an
actor the one I enjoyed filming the most
I'm gonna give you three one was in that
big finale with the shooter when my
character like participated in saving
Derek's life and be handling pressure
the other two were the Jay prole the
movie episode 1 of Montana and the other
one that was all flashbacks
not a fan what do you mean and the other
episodes I loved by the ones I directed
what's my biggest pet peeve vagueness
takes just as much time to be specific
what was it like playing oh you've
chosen some other ones too so we've got
a queue here what was it like playing
Marcus on Detroit become human and what
was your favorite ending playing Marcus
in Detroit was dope it was awesome it
was a lot of work it was way harder than
I thought it would be my favorite ending
is when I live so I'll accept anything
where you don't get me killed so that I
won't ask for much
it used to be high school teacher in
Philly what made you want to transition
from teaching the acting that was hard
the hardest decision I ever made was
transitioning I had no thought of being
an actor at that point I just knew that
I had creative ambitions I wanted to
write films and shoot films and I didn't
want to grow to resent my kids because I
was staying in the classroom which was
the best job I've ever had I miss it
very dearly would you be down a new
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants 3
they've offered me this job many times
and the whole franchise really hinging
on whether I say yes or not
no no if I'm speaking out of turn but if
they if the money's right is what I told
them but I told the head of the studio
you know pay me none of that is intended
to be a factual statement was there a
defining moment in your life that made
you want to be an advocate for change
and it was probably when I
move to the suburbs and saw how very
very differently people were treated
there than where I grew up in Chicago
then that didn't feel right at all or
fair or necessary so I figure there must
be a way okay I've already rolled the
pants down to a sufficient height so you
could also enjoy the socks it's not like
the fashion police dog what shows are
you obsessed with right now I am behind
on Game of Thrones
just the three episodes so don't spoil
anything I desperately missed Colbert I
am just now discovering the Oh a and
trying to get caught up so I can see the
second season tell us your most
memorable and most embarrassing run-ins
with a celebrity I did once at a party
walk up to an embrace an actress because
I thought we were long I thought we were
friends and coworkers and mid hug I
realized I don't know her at all and
whispered in her ear I don't actually
know you do I
she said nope and I calmly let her go
and slowly backed out of the room that's
a true story that happened in Shonda
Rhimes home and I didn't realize I
hadn't not been invited back ever since
I should text her what's one role you
got turned down for but really wanted
there's a joke answer two real answers a
few roles that I've really wanted and
gotten but then lost because of my
activism those can rename remain
nameless there was a movie that I when I
first came to town help you girls out
you want to get both those aren't and
they're not expensive it's fine it was a
movie called battle la battle of Los
Angeles that I tested for like three
times and was promised a job and then
didn't get it but if I had if I had
gotten it I would have not have been in
town for grades and would have never
gotten grades you know sometimes
rejection is protection
she's clearly my favorite and I'm hers
hurry up probably or James Brown if you
could create the perfect series ending
to graze what would it be everybody died
in a fiery blaze I'm pitching that next
week it's gonna tie these that you can
untie them and further destroy my
Footwear
do you have a Grey's Anatomy group chat
No thank God we worked together 15 hours
a day the last thing I want is a text
from them our group is pretty
irresponsible so we're likely to text
things accidentally like talk about each
other I can I say that with puppies in
the room what's one song everyone should
have on their playlist well stay on
theme anything by Frank Ocean right now
my my lady's okay
discipline is important my biggest
childhood fear what scares you know I
was an adult biggest childhood fear was
probably the police and my web scares me
now achieving my goals scared of the
cops anymore that a cop I'll also add
that all these puppies here with us
today
very well tempered are up for adoption
at North Shore Animal League America so
make sure to reach out have a heart and
adopt one if not two amazing puppies you
can't have this thanks so much this has
been playing with puppies the daily show
with your host Jesse Williams and come
again
[Music]